uh I'd like to kindly introduce deputy
director for Socom focused on
acquisition technology and Logistics
Mr Bill Innis
[Applause]
all right thanks Mike thanks everybody
um good afternoon again uh
I think this is where I make a joke
about starting right after lunch
um
that was it actually so I don't actually
have one um I am billennis I'm the
deputy director of Special Operations
forces acquisition technology and
Logistics I'll talk a little bit about
what that that means from an Authority's
perspective but my focus will be on the
on the capabilities themselves supported
by technology that are important to our
special operations forces operators
which is why we in soft ATM now exist
and I'll wrap up with a few thoughts on
the threats and challenges we're
wrestling with in soft 18l every day
I'll be hitting the tech pretty high
level I'm looking forward to hearing the
experts discuss in more detail how Tech
AI ml Quantum data for example in
particular can help fill in any gaps and
challenges we see and how we how we
better access it
um so on the next slide Point anywhere
probably huh
there we go a real quick agenda I'm
going to start with a video and uh again
I'll start with our authorities how
we're structured as a bit of a baseline
in soft 18l then talk about our
processes the technology Focus areas
that we have in the command and key
capabilities and programs associated
with those Tech Focus areas made a few
changes to the rollout so it doesn't
follow exactly that but but close enough
and I may bring up a few points as I go
through this I've kind of taken some
notes through the first half of the
discussion I really like that that early
part of the discussion obviously uh
acquisition and how fast we move is
always always a challenge and what our
requirements are in Legacy programs and
moving on to the next Generations always
tough and DOD acquisition I think we're
pretty good at it in Socom I've done
acquisition in a number of places Air
Force Navy even a little time with the
army so I really enjoyed being at soft
18 now so I do think we do it better
there than anywhere else so I'm going to
start with the video it is about uh six
minutes you should see a few things that
I'll come back to in the next few slides
slides it's really just One Maritime
focused vignette and we could we do a
number of these and we could do any
number of them but I think it's pretty
good kind of for this forum to highlight
some of those areas that you know will
drive this discussion some of the tech
areas we're focused on so about six
minutes
the 2018 National defense strategy
articulates that the U.S military will
face increased Global disorder
characterized by decline in the
long-standing rules-based international
order creating a security environment
more complex and volatile than any
experienced in recent memory the
re-emergence of long-term strategic
competition rapid dispersion of
Technologies and new concepts of warfare
and competition that spans the entire
spectrum of conflict requires a Joint
Force to meet the challenges of this
reality
adversaries anti-access area denial a2ad
capabilities aimed to create a broad
area of Maritime surveillance capability
targeting system and contested comms
environment CCE that in time of conflict
would render the existing Naval and
Joint platform architecture increasingly
vulnerable
recognizing the increasing complex
security environment the AI for maritime
manure Futures concept was designed to
employ AI Edge compute specialized
Communications and robotic autonomy in
Maritime soft man unmanned teams in a
highly unique manner to tip the balance
of power in multi-domain a2ad
competition space to our advantage today
and into the future
artificial intelligence for maritime
maneuver addresses those key problems
faced in the future operating
environment to gain maintain and extend
access into the adversary's competition
space while enabling The Joint Forces
decision advantage and the application
of scalable effects with enhanced
precision
Hallmarks of the aim concept AI enabled
soft Maritime craft and seasoned
operators self deception mass and
precision are intended to penetrate the
adversary's defenses complicate enemy
kill chains and ensure own Force
lethality and survivability
future success will increasingly go to
the actor who can best gather data
process it into actionable information
and team with Partners both human and
machine in real time
Maritime soft with specialized low
observable craft and focused
applications of AI and autonomy teamed
with multi-domain unmanned systems can
extend its access swarming from the sea
through the littoral commons and Inland
to directly enable scalable and mass
effects on scene but unseen
the aim concept takes advantage of
Cutting Edge usage of onboard compute
data artificial intelligence and
specialized Communications or AI enabled
Mission autonomy in small uxs to deploy
within range of adversary targets
enabling AI autonomous systems to detect
classify and identify a Moines to
provide enhanced Precision of targeting
the fires platforms enabling a clear
decision advantage
critical to the success of these
missions is all domain awareness
alternative pnt Mission autonomy and
tactical intelligence at the edge and
specialized Communications on demand
while ensuring Mission command
deliberately and discreetly networked to
the Joint Force
given their low observable small size
Mission autonomy and tactical
intelligence at the edge AI enable
robotic systems in Maritime soft man
unmanned teams are uniquely positioned
to excel in their ability to gain
maintain and extend access into highly
contested environments
and on above and under Maritime Soft C
strike portfolio of access mass and
precision could provide the Joint Force
with a broader spectrum of unique
options to create more complex dilemmas
for defeating adversaries
aim expands the maritime strike
warfare's ability to achieve kinetic
effects on a broader variety of targets
that might have otherwise been
inaccessible
aim promises to shrink the competition
bubble in highly contested a2ad
environments by employing AI enabled
Maritime soft man unmanned teams
operating far forward in contested
environments to deliver kinetic and
non-kinetic effects including
unprecedented access to sub T and mobile
launch sites ultimately removing cover
and concealment from our opponents while
providing targeting quality data to the
Joint Force AI for automated Target
detection tracking cross queuing and
command and control will further expand
the ways in which the maritime soft man
unmanned team can enable joint Warfare
with speed precision and mass efficiency
to support the effects kill chain
the artificial intelligence for maritime
maneuver Futures concept leverages
Maritime soft capabilities envisioned to
operate in new and unique ways when
empowered by Ai and autonomous systems
to operate in Maritime soft man unmanned
teams to solve critical operational
problems of the future operating
environment
the AI enabled Maritime soft man on man
team provides a collection of unique
scalable capabilities that will enable
The Joint Force to compete and win in
complex contested and denied
environments across the competition
continue this is what the nation expects
from Special Operations
[Music]
okay that is a conceptual video If you
will but a lot of it is uh in reality in
terms of what we're going after today
and what we're moving moving dollars to
we're having a conversation over lunch
you follow the dollars show me your
dollars I can show you your strategy and
we're definitely moving a lot of dollars
into that space
okay so organizationally I did want to
start start off with this a lot of folks
in the room probably know all about this
but
um you know
I want to establish the foundation to
capture where we as an acquisition fit
in in the overall organization Socom
founded in 1987 out of the failed Iran
hostage rescue operation almost
everybody in here knows that Congress
forced the dod to establish a joint
command to ensure not we had not only
the best individual service operators
but the best cross service team and that
wasn't just in the operation side but
also in the acquisition support side of
it as well they want us to have the
acquisition authority to get after our
joint needs
um there are two sides of Socom makes it
unique in DOD uh Ms Logan talked about
it earlier in terms of the two sides of
Socom on one side's the the left side
here your left side is the operational
side and then on the right side is the
organized training equip side the
component commands afsock uses sock War
com marshock closely aligned to that
right side but showing here down the
middle is the acquisition Authority and
that's what we in soft 18l execute by
law we are responsible to the commander
General Fenton with advocacy from ASD
solic to deliver soft peculiar equipment
and services to soft operators with
congressionally appropriated dollars
that's really important of course we do
that in close collaboration with the
components with the operators with the
big services but primarily through
through contracts with the defense
industrial base So Soft operators need a
new capability it's soft 18l's
responsibility and legal authority to
provide it so again just a little bit of
a Baseline and this is what the uh this
is who executes that Authority
organizationally Mr Smith at the bottom
there is the acquisition executive
negative the second and third rows are
the program executive officers who
deliver the capability in their domain
areas supported by the top row most
importantly Miss Lisa Sanders in the
Science and Technology shop her work
which includes close collaboration with
Labs Academia industry fines and helps
integrate technology our peos and
ultimately our operators finds and helps
integrate our the technology our peos
and ultimately The Operators need peos
work on Tech too but that really is
least is 100 Focus it's akin to the
separate and now separate acquisition
and sustainment shops at the OSD level
led by Dr Laplante and the research and
Engineering shop led by a Miss Heidi Shu
but again we're still Under One Roof at
silicon to to our benefit I think I
wanted to highlight as well some of the
specific areas that are focused on in
this conversation I think is peo soft
digital applications you know strictly
focused on soft applications software
applications we just stood that one up
recently peo special reconnaissance and
middle there peo in the upper left
command control Communications and
computers all important of course peo
Maritime Randy slap they work very
closely together it's one of the
challenges I think as uh as you know
integration changes I guess and becomes
more important is tying all the peos
together but I think we do that a pretty
good job at Socom
um I also want to point out Master Chief
Steve White on the in the bottom left
there he is our Navy SEAL senior
enlisted leader really important to have
that operator in the loop and you know
make sure we maintain our North Star
there that's who we're here to support
and just a conversation of size this is
about 900 people and that's 900 of the
6000 that was mentioned earlier so
acquisition is is unique in that regard
like centcom and Joint staff they don't
have an acquisition shop so this is a
big big piece of that I'll tell you that
you know we have we've done a lot of a
lot of data runs on that and uh you know
the experience that I have I'll tell you
we need more people I know it was
brought up earlier but uh you know in
terms of the complexity and the size of
the Oregon the contracts that rewarding
that we're working on we haven't changed
that much in the last 10 years but our
rdtne and procurement dollars have gone
up and it is one of the things that I
lose sleep over is our Workforce our
work-life balance there is a real
Challenge and we're in a war for talent
so it's something we're constantly
working on or we need a heck of a lot
less bureaucracy to the point I think
that was made and I think that is
increasing as well but uh this is the
group that that delivers the capability
okay
uh high level Tech uh Tech pathway
process the endpoint really is the block
of programs of record on the on the
right here
um that that's really the capability
delivery
um and um
we're really you know part of that the
platforms and services which is on my
last slide is you know it was all kind
of sum up but up front I wanted to
provide an overview how we drive Tech
into those capabilities we don't buy
tech for Tech's sake we buy capabilities
and the tech help us helps us meet those
capabilities uh someone May challenge me
on that but it was brought up last night
you know Tech in terms like AI hey let's
just sprinkle some AI on that you know
we're still after the capability and
what can Tech do to help us to deliver
those capabilities
um and maybe that's something we need to
talk about more at a higher level again
the discussion that we had earlier about
uh you know where soft is moving in
terms of 130s and drones you know mq
ones and q9s you know what is next
Generation
Um you know what is the capability we
really need the slide is probably an
oversimplification it's generally not
linear but overall it starts with the
top down directions from General Fenton
and secretary Mary on the guidance
documents all fed by the national
defense strategy up up at the top
um and uh our focus is on the circle
which I'll highlight you know and you
know provides us with those six
technology Focus areas which I'll
highlight in the next next slide more
detail but it's also Bottoms Up with
inputs from the operator in the field
again critically important to us it's
who we support not only do they feed us
inputs from our data calls and cross
components as s t councils but if they
see something commercial Tech that they
like or maybe more relevant today in in
this forum uh something a foreign
partner has you know we just came from
the Ukraine discussion Roundtable there
and you know some of the things they're
doing overseas we need to do a better
job of adapting that adopting that and
the the lessons that they're learning
over there are enormous so we need to
stay close to our operators who are
seeing that on the front line they have
authority but if the operators see that
they have the authority to try it out
and if it's useful we'll fold it into
one of those programs of record and get
it to the whole force with Congressional
appropriations of course given those
Focus areas Lisa Sanders and our s t
shop as well as the peos execute
strategic strategic engagements like
this one Futures efforts resulting in
the conceptual video that I showed
earlier uh to drive thinking on
operational Concepts and gaps and
experimentation where we bring in our
partners to demonstrate current or
nascent Tech to see how it might meet
our capability in an operational
environment we have two of those coming
up this year actually in contested comms
and Next Generation ISR so that's kind
of the cycle that that's the tech that
Tech analysis uh smt type work that
feeds everything in the upper right in
terms of the the programs that we
execute
so these uh Tech Focus areas breaking
them down a little bit further with a
couple of quick examples we're
interested in in biotech such as
repeated blast exposure impacts to
operators Next Generation ISR mentioned
that a few times including space in
cyber it's not just about the drones
these days although that still is
important Network and data management
Sensor Fusion hyper-enabled operator
optical character recognition natural
language processing
information dominance if you will is a
big part of that next Generation
Precision strike loitering Munitions is
uh popular these days so to speak and a
Next Generation Mobility including
expeditionary Logistics which is a which
is a big deal
um acknowledging these are fairly Broad
and there's some overlap I'd suggest
AIML data Computing enhance all of them
it does give us some guidance and
boundaries with limited resources and I
think you saw a number of those if not
all in in that video especially how all
the sensors and Associated comms and
data would be linked together to
hyper-enable our operators on Mobility
platforms employing various effects
and what do those capability platforms
look like here's a high level overview
not all inclusive we like to say we
deliver everything from satellites to
submarines which is true the slides
broken down by domain capability areas
including the ground air and Maritime
for portfolios on the left
um I did Colonel I want to dig into the
not dig into but I'm going to check my
numbers I worked on the F-22 program
back in 2004 five and six and I'm pretty
sure that was more expensive than
ac-130j so that got my the F-22
165 according to Wiki which is never
wrong
well 2006 it was over 200 million and
there was always a gimmick that they
pulled where they didn't include the
engine so
um but uh anyway I I will uh I will look
that up but it got my attention having
worked on F22 when we went to full rate
production anyway um as I noted you'll
see some of the things from the video
already in our formations uh the
combatant craft the underseat craft
drones uh Precision strike Munitions but
very clearly I think we have gaps is in
the last three rows and comms and data
particularly and that's interesting
because the department is still fairly
decent I think delivering purely defense
related capabilities uh some of the
hardware uh defense related capabilities
although it probably does cost too much
and take too long I think we'd all
probably agree with that but we still
kind of lead lead the league so so to
speak in that but we primarily lag and
when it comes to areas that are now
driven by the commercial sector uh so 40
years ago I think we LED in all of these
areas but now we're just desperately
trying to keep up again comms data
networks and software in particularly we
have the hardware in a lot of ways but
fusing all that data together and high
bandwidth networks operating contested
and congested environments using AIML
tools and high-powered compute may be
disconnected from the broader Network to
process the data and Feed The Operators
to make make the right decisions at
speed and not only kinetic strike
scenarios but sentiment analysis and
information operations information
dominance in all of that put together
you know that's the Crux of the
challenge that we're facing
okay last slide and these are really uh
my questions
um and uh final thoughts and a Twist you
know the questions I'm presenting the
group and it's really the things that we
wrestle with with every day at soft 18l
I'd be interested in kind of the
panelist thoughts on this final thoughts
to consider particularly related to the
threats and challenges inherent in these
key technologies that support our
operators support our capabilities first
is security cyber security working with
non-traditional DOD commercial providers
in a classified environment
higher levels of encryption required for
military products we can't just give our
operators iPhones at least I don't think
that we can the viability of our
encryption tools in the face of quantum
powered threats Supply chains not just
robust Supply chains but trusted Supply
chains all of these security concerns
are in balance with the ever increasing
need for interoperability and
integration with allies and partners
which we've talked a lot about here
today and that's key to the socom
Mission always has and always will be I
think it's almost a perfect
contradiction locking our capabilities
down but exporting them to or
integrating with a partners and allies
second is how do we keep Pace with or
even get ahead of industry I've read
estimates that DOD is less than one
percent of the integrated circuit market
and Socom is two percent of of the dod
budget higher if you include the
services three percent four percent
somewhere in there I think are there
paths to influence to meet our our needs
our security needs our defense related
uses do we need different business and
financial arrangements with willing
Partners Congress has improved
acquisition I think in our ability to
keep up with the commercial sector with
OTAs and mtas you hear these these
acronyms about Contracting approaches
and acquisition approaches and that's
helped but I do think we need to do
better it's not enough because the
threats and the technology in the
commercial sector is changing so fast
and third is what risk are we willing to
take with the AIML driven tools and how
we use them there's probably a little
risk in using these tools for sentiment
analysis we talked a little bit about
hostile in hostile environments we're
maintaining our aircraft we kind of
talked about that for example but how
far off are we from really using AIML
tools to help us make kinetic decisions
or information
operations decisions or electromagnetic
dominance decisions how far off are we
from from using that and is our risk
calculus that different than our
competitors and enemies almost almost
certainly I think the answer is yes
there
um so
um that's how I'll wrap it up I'm about
to get the hook actually
rather abruptly I guess but I'll turn it
over to the panel this is what we in
soft18l do these you kind of did a quick
run through of our technology Focus
areas and what I see is the challenges
and threats against us uh against us but
that's what we do make sure that our
operators have far more capability which
requires the best technology uh than the
enemy so thank you and I don't know if I
have time for questions maybe I did that
you know when drones first sort of
arrived on the scene U.S Air Force was
always very keen to sort of say you know
there's always going to be a human in
the loop and when I was watching the
video I mean well that that you played
um where will a human be in that in that
Loop given all these unmanned AI driven
yeah I don't know for sure that I have
the the answer to that exactly like
physically where that individual will be
whether it's the operator on the
combatant craft that you saw or
um you know at the uh at the operational
command level
um at you know using our mission command
platform which we're building under
peostda so it's probably a combination
of both I guess to clarify when there
will always be a human in the loop when
the decision is made to kill somebody
was the sort of operating idea that the
US Air Force had is that basically like
we're just completely past that point
and it's not even worth a discussion or
today I think it is I think we're past
that point yeah yes sir
do you agree with that or you don't
agree with that I I don't know enough
but it just it seems that we are in a
situation where these machines will
simply be fighting each other and the
humans will be
almost entirely absent
I personally think we're a long way off
from that but I understand your comment
of course
this man
for those really cool systems that you
showed in the initial video how
important will it be to have if we're
thinking about the indo-pacific access
to Bases or places with allies and
partners to do maintenance or resupply
of some of those platforms
um yeah good question depending on how
they are being used and depending on the
scenario I guess I'm getting a little
out of my Lane there but uh
um you know as it stands now it's not
critically important but if we have no
you know access over there it would be a
pretty big problem
is the short answer that makes sense a
really vague kind of answer to your
question though I'm afraid
yes sir hey Bill what what are your top
five ongoing program acquisitions
oh in terms of dollars
um
I want to answer that with our priority
programs
um and it would be like our mission
command which I mentioned earlier a
common operating picture it would be
counter uas it's really important to us
armed OverWatch you mentioned is one of
our important programs and you know I'm
the acquisition guy I get the
requirement and the money and I go
execute but in the counterterrorism
fight which we still have to maintain we
do believe that is an affordable
effective way to provide that armed
OverWatch so the bigger force can go do
their big thing against a great power
competition
um what's the next one undersea
portfolio is really important dry combat
submersibles the dcs's
um and uh let me think about
next one probably
um now that's four that pop into my head
data is huge data is absolutely huge to
us you know and I didn't you know in the
video they called it aim but we are
working uh you know it's not that same
acronym but like I said in the next few
years we're definitely advancing the
amount of money we're spending on that
very concept so that's a really
important program to us in the maritime
portfolio thank you sir
uh yes sir uh how tight end is so calm
with the Venture Capital Community when
you're looking to find some of these
solutions for the requirements that we
have
not as close as we would like to be but
we are putting a lot of effort into that
um absolutely putting a lot of effort
into that and it's an important uh
something that General Fenton our
commander of course is pushing for
actually
um he's had a few sessions with some of
the Venture Capital folks that are
interested in doing business with us
down at the headquarters and our
softworks platform if you've heard of
that that's our partnership intermediary
agreement that does a lot of Outreach
for us there are neutral non non-profit
that that helps us with Outreach with
small businesses they're also holding
regular events now as a matter of fact
it's ongoing where they're going to do
the next iteration of tying Venture
Capital companies that want to do
business with with DOD and want to
invest in you know these types of
companies with the small businesses with
our requirements talking a lot about
what I just showed up here today so it's
definitely a growth area not where we
want to be yet but we're pushing hard on
that
it gets a little bit to what I said I
think we needed to do better in terms of
our business arrangements and financial
Arrangements if we can you know tighten
that up I think that's going to be
really good for for what we do
[Applause]
[Music]